it's a pleasure and an honor to be here
1979 is 30 years ago now it's amazing
how quickly the time goes I'd like to
start by thanking RJ View for for the
wonderful leadership you've had when I
was a student here and also for
sponsoring this event as and bringing
CFOs just back to Stanford I'd also like
to thank Jim Jim Van Horn who was one of
my finance professors back at Stanford
and is one of the reasons why I was I've
been able to have a successful finance
career and Jack I I tried to get into
your class and it was oversubscribed
because it was too popular but I hope
I'll get a chance to take your class now
now that I'm back in the valley
sure I still have a lot to learn so just
what a wonderful faculty and leadership
you all have the privilege of having and
I I'm very grateful to to you all for
having giving me this education and the
opportunity that I've had as Jack said
what I'd like to do is to start by
talking to you about how I got from
being a graduate student to being the
CFO at Oracle it's I would say a unique
career path it was not at all direct and
you'll get a chance to see that if we
have time I'll talk more about a little
bit more about Oracle and I'd be happy
to spend a fair amount of time on
questions I'll start with let's see if I
can get this slide to work I'll start
with something that when I was a student
I would attend these sessions with
executives and what I always wanted to
know is what's the secret of your
success how did how did you get to be
successful so I'll tell a story of when
I was a student I attended a session
like this and the speaker was Baron de
Rothschild of the Rothschild banking
family and we asked what was the secret
of your success to him and he said that
when he was a small boy he lived in the
country outside of Paris and he noticed
he was always interested in business he
noticed that there was a price
difference between the price of products
in the country compared to the city and
so one day he bought an apple for one
franc in the country and he went to
school in the city so every day he'd go
to the school in the city and that that
day he sold the Apple for two francs
because the price difference and the
second day he had his two francs he
bought two apples and he went to the
city and he sold it for 4 francs the
next day he bought 4 apples
and he said he did that every day for
six months until his great-uncle died
and left him 900 million francs
so the the that was a very important
lesson for me let's let's move on to to
my career I want to start when I was in
college is to give you a sense of the
environment that I was in as I as after
jack and I spoke and I decided to write
this presentation about my career I
realized how important what was going on
in the economy in the world was two
decisions that I made in my career and
the code here is things that are in blue
on the right are things that were
happening in the world things that are
black and on the left is what I did in
terms of my career so while I was in
college I was very interested in news
and information and politics Watergate
happened and Nixon resigned essentially
because of the reporting from Woodward
Bernstein I read all the president's men
I saw the movie I thought this was
fascinating and I wondered could that be
part of my career and I'll show you in a
little while how it came back to that in
1975 Apple was founded down the road
from here I had no idea that Apple
existed but now of course we all know
Apple but this was going on in the
environment in Silicon Valley also in
1975 I don't know if you could recognize
the guy in the bottom left Bill Gates
starting Microsoft when they were very
early on had never didn't hear Microsoft
and night until later on actually I'll
tell that story now in I was the class
of 79 Steve Ballmer was the class of
1980
and you may have heard him or her he's
been here but he during the summer
during the summer at between between his
two years he won both a BCG and a Bane
award to try it for us to try to recruit
him and I was at BCG and he turned us
both down to join Microsoft and be the
thirtieth employee of Microsoft and we
just thought that that was the most
silly decision that someone could
possibly do to drop that to turn down
BCG to drop out of Stanford Business
School to go work for this little
company know when it heard of and we all
we all thought that Steve had made a
terrible career mistake but I guess
twenty billion dollars later it turns
out he was he was writing and we didn't
see the future fair enough for now
so then 1975 I watched a lot of
television when I was growing up I
didn't realize how important cable
television and satellite television was
HBO which had been available locally put
its signal on the satellite
Jerry Levin who was running HBO was
responsible for that ultimately became
the CEO of Time Warner because of this
business decision again I didn't know
this was happening but it became
important later on in my career so I was
sort of in on the beginning of these I
sir was vaguely aware of the personal
computer industry of the cable
television industry and in 1977 the man
on the right is Larry Ellison founded
Oracle and I didn't I had never heard of
Oracle either so that brings me up to
that was what happened while I was in
college I went straight to from college
to business school that's me on the left
there I was a little younger and thinner
back in 1979 with my dad and and then I
thought about okay well how did I get
from 1979 being that skinny young kid to
where I am now and of course the
shortest distance between two points is
a straight line and I will describe how
my career has not quite been a straight
line so what did I do I went right out
of business school just up the road to
2180 Sand Hill Road
remember that address because it turns
out to be important I was a consultant
at the Boston Consulting Group wonderful
experience I learned a lot worked in
lots of different cases they had in
college we had HP calculators they
didn't have personal computer in college
in business school didn't have computers
at by the time I got to BCG we started
to use computers and they invented this
wonderful new software called busy calc
which let us do spreadsheets and models
and calculations and I thought this was
terrific as now I didn't have to
actually handwrite information on
physical spreadsheets which is how we
used to do things so I was I was
beginning to understand a little bit
about technology as a user because I had
a liberal arts undergraduate degree and
and was not did not have an IT
background in 1981 while I was at BCG
IBM launched the PC so we all got IBM
pcs and we thought that was pretty
interesting this is one of the early
versions of the PC and so I was having
fun working on these lots of different
projects the one on the left is KGMB
channel 9
Honolulu one of my clients was Lee
Enterprises which owned that TV station
and I was doing Studies on understanding
the television station business the
television programming business flying
back and forth to Honolulu we worked on
two studies at the same time at BCG then
and the other client was shale chemical
company so I was flying to Houston to
the Houston industrial port and working
on the epoxy resin business which is
poison and smells like poison and I was
look at these two businesses saying one
of these is more fun than the other and
I said well this is pretty interesting I
can think about my career I always
wanted to work in a company as opposed
to as an advisor and I said maybe
there's a way I can take my interest in
media and television and have that be a
career the picture at the bottom right
is Allen spoon who was a partner at the
Boston Consulting Group at the time and
for my good fortune the Washington Post
Company hired Allen in 1982 to be the
director to be the vice president of
corporate development in charge of
strategic planning
Allen hired me and I moved to Washington
I made the mistake of leaving Silicon
Valley in a very exciting time in 1982
but that brought me back to the East
Coast and I got to work with the
Washington Post Company of course where
Woodward Bernstein worked which was back
why Watergate was important when I was
in college so here I was in Washington
working as director of business
development strategy and acquisitions
for what I felt was one of the greatest
media companies in the world it was
incredibly exciting to be working at
this company with Ben Bradley was the
editor and those of you who've read
about that period of the post what an
extraordinary time to be there
Kathryn Graham's family controlled the
company she was the chairman of the
board actually she was the CEO when I
first joined just a remarkable woman
also on the board was Warren Buffett who
was a major shareholder of the company
and I had a chance to present to to the
board and to Warren and bought my first
share of of Berkshire Hathaway stock
back in 1983 and of course another I
think 19 year member of the Washington
Post Board of Directors was RJ Miller so
it was wonderful to have RJ on the
Washington Post company board and have
the connection back back to Stanford so
this is I love the business I loved
working at the
post company and had a terrific time one
of the things that Allen spoon decided
to do was get involved in the mobile
telephone business there were no mobile
telephones in the United States in 1981
the technology was just developed the
FCC decided to give away licenses for
free now they sell these licenses for
tens of billions of dollars at the time
they were giving them away for free the
Washington Post which had started out as
a newspaper got in the radio business
when radio was invented got in the
television business of television was
invented and Allen spoon said if they're
giving away licenses for free I don't
care what it's for we're going to make a
lot of money if we get one and we had
about a period of six weeks from the
time we learned about this to the time
the applications were due so I actually
wrote the marketing plan for cellular
telephones at a time when there were
zero cellular customers the United
States trying to predict how many mobile
phone customers they're going to be and
you can see that that was an early
version of the mobile phone you can see
how convenient compact they were back
then and we all knew that the mobile
phone industry was going to be huge so
here's a chart in retrospect 20/20
hindsight just showing how courses
started from nothing to the point where
now everyone has mobile phones all
around the world did I invest in this
business personally no did I actually
quit The Washington Post Company to go
work full-time for a mobile phone
company no why I didn't take advantage
of this I have no idea I knew I was
sitting there right there in the middle
the birth of this entire industry I saw
it and I somehow I just didn't make that
leap in my own mind to say I can either
as an investor or as an employee an
executive become part of this phenomenal
growth trend and I still can't figure
out how I missed it but I missed it I
just I was so focused on the excitement
of being in the media business and the
television newspaper business that I
thought in a mobile phones
communications that's really that's
technical let's let someone else do that
so I missed enormous opportunities by
not taking advantage of that meanwhile
Lotus came out and was invented and
overtook visicalc so from a personal
point of view of what I did every day
doing spreadsheets and analysis this
actually had a big impact in my life and
I immediately started to use Lotus which
is pretty interesting to see how that
technology evolved
and and then in 1984 prodigy came out
which was an early version of sort of an
internet like type of thing and I don't
know why I was interested in this type
of thing but it was sort of media sort
of communications sort of involved in
technology and I became an early
subscriber to prodigy and I I wasn't
using it every day but I had email I
used that I was trying to figure out
from a consumer point of view what this
is all about and it was slow and clunky
and terrible to use but you could tell
the world was going to change you could
tell that people eventually we're not
going to cut down trees make paper print
on that paper and take the take trucks
and take that paper to people's homes to
deliver news and information if you were
if you're in the news and information
business you knew that with computers
and communication that our industry was
going to change this is back in in 25
years ago now okay so I'm at the
Washington Post company I have what I
had a wonderful job I loved working
there it was a terrific but Wall Street
beckoned so 1984 I became an investment
banker why you might ask well it's
pretty easy to understand why they pay a
lot of money so they offered to double
my compensation and I went back to Allen
spoon and I said I have this job offer
to join first Boston they're gonna pay
me twice as much how long will it take
me to double my salary here he said a
long time Jeff but it's a wonderful
company it's a great place to work you
have all these other benefits and I said
I'm gonna go for the money so I moved to
New York and became a media investment
banker working for Bruce Washington on
the left and Joe Pirela on the right at
the first Boston Corporation two of the
the marquee names in Wall Street
investment banking just an extraordinary
place to work in the mid 80s first
Boston was one of the leading M&A shops
and very interestingly if you go back
and look at the history Goldman Sachs
and Morgan Stanley were the two probably
leading investment banks at first Boston
was it I said a teardown so all the
clients were Goldman clients or Morgan
Stanley clients which means that we at
first Boston were always the insurgent
we had to go in and get a client away
from Goldman and Morgan Stanley which
meant we were more aggressive we were I
think we worked hard
we were doing cold calls it was a very
exciting time to be there and I learned
a lot from Bruce and Jojo now has his
own firm for many years was the head of
Morgan Stanley's the best banking
practice and Bruce ended up buying
controlling interest in lazar and is now
the chairman of lizard at the time bet
back to that was my personal career back
to what's happening in the world
AOL starts in 1985 remember I was an
early prodigy subscriber I then became
an AOL subscriber and said well this is
a lot better it was a Windows interface
1985 what's that 20 24 years ago now so
it's it's amazing how long it's been but
I I clearly had the sense that something
was going on there so from a personal
and consumer basis I was excited
meanwhile I'm still working as an
investment banker I represented the ABC
network selling to capital cities
communications sold the New Yorker
magazine sold the Des Moines Register
very a lot of activity in media I had a
lot of fun I learned a lot and one of my
clients was King world productions which
distributes Wheel of Fortune jeopardy in
the Oprah Winfrey Show and they actually
the way I got King World as a client was
I had a list of the top 100 media
companies and I made a list of all the
companies and who at first Boston was
the partner who called on those
companies and King world was the largest
company without a first Boston partner
calling on them because I couldn't call
on the ones that already had a first
Boston partner calling on so I called
cold called them and said I'm from first
Boston I want to talk to you about the
great things we could do and they said
come on over and meet with me I couldn't
believe it it was I didn't really expect
them to say yes so I got to know them
and I ended up doing some work with them
and then they ended up offering me to
join them as chief financial officer so
it's now 1988 so I'm nine years out of
Business School and I think I've died
and gone to heaven I'm now the chief
financial officer of a New York Stock
Exchange very profitable company with
these wonderful shows
small business at the time we had only
300 employees but we had the three
highest-rated daily shows and television
and ultimately I was there for six years
we grew to about five hundred million in
revenue with a hundred fifty million
dollars in operating profit with five
hundred employees so just incredibly
profitable because of these wonderful
shows run by Roger King who was
an entrepreneur whose family had started
the company and is now passed away but
it's an extraordinarily sales talent
just someone who dropped out of high
school completely untrained unschooled
but a great natural entrepreneur a great
salesperson charismatic man and built
built a company up and it was very
successful company the stock price
tripled during the six years that I was
there and I learned how to be a CFO in
retrospect I don't know that I would
have hired me as a CFO because I didn't
know what I was doing my first year but
they had a good accountant good
controller it was a simple company
because it was small and I sort of
learned on the job about a number of
things having to do with how do you
become a CFO while I was there Microsoft
Office comes out takes over Lotus so
here you have VisiCalc that essentially
died Lotus isn't quite dead but clearly
diminished and microsoft office took
over the world 1993 was the probably the
first time I heard about the internet
this was a this is a cover story in
broadcasting magazine so I'm hearing
about the internet by reading a
television trade magazine and television
companies newspaper companies sort of
had the sense that their world was going
to change once the internet came out
1994 Netscape comes out and that really
made a big difference people when
Netscape went public all of a sudden it
became front-page business news and it
wasn't just sort of the industry trades
it's now everyone was talking about the
Internet and in 1995 do I join the
Internet no I I know the Internet's
gonna be huge it's clear that it's going
to change the world but I was pretty
risk-averse and I said you know what I
want to do is I want to join an offline
company that can migrate to online
because I don't know if the Internet's
going to take five years to develop or
25 years to develop and I want to have a
profitable business which can can can
tweak it where we can dial it up or down
depending on the development of the
business so I met socially at this guy
Walter Forbes in the bottom right who is
the CEO of CUC which was a large direct
marketing company mostly direct mail and
telemarketing and they were already on
America Online but it was clear that
their services could be sold through the
internet and direct marketing I knew is
going to be huge in the internet so I
said this is great I can come in
and I started in corporate development I
then moved over to being a general
manager to running Auto Vantage which is
a triple-a type of service which also
has a car buying service like auto buy
tell which helps you buy cars through
the AOL or through the internet and get
discounts from car dealers so I put Auto
Vantage on the internet for the first
time I developed a new revenue stream of
advertising from car dealers which
supplemented the the membership that
we're getting from consumers and got my
first experience in being a general
manager so I'd been a consultant and a
banker then the CFO and I thought I
wanted to be a CEO so the way to be a
CEO is to move out of this finance sort
of on the one hand being a CFO is
terrific from from getting your I guess
what I would say from a career point of
view I got my my ticket punched so from
then on anytime anyone was looking for a
mid-cap media CFO they would call me
because I had been a public company
media CFO but to make the leap from
being a CFO to CEO was difficult because
people didn't want to hire CEO if you
hadn't already been a CEO so I figured
if I could become a general manager I
get P&L responsibility I could
eventually become a CEO that was the
theory in the meantime Walter Forbes is
committing accounting fraud and is now
in jail
CUC is became merged with Cendant and
evidently this accounting fraud was
going on during the time that I was
there I fortunately didn't work in the
finance department so I didn't know
about it but it turned out that when
this is disclosed send in stock market
value drop by thirteen billion dollars
in one day Walter and the president were
both actually in jail so just incredible
story about corporate ethics and and
compliance so 1998 I now have this line
experience but double-click calls and
says where the Internet is actually a
business now we've got growing revenues
we're looking for a public company CFO
someone who's got CFO experience has got
media and advertising experience will
you come and join us as CFO I said I
probably wouldn't have joined if it was
three months earlier but they were
actually about to go public goldman
sachs is the underwriter I joined the
day of the IPO which meant that I knew
we had 30
in dollars and cash in the bank even
though we were losing money and I
figured with 30 million dollars in the
cash in the bank we at least could last
a year or two so that it just barely
made my risk profile which of course
would have been a terrible decision if I
had come three months earlier and said
no because it's too risky but
doubleclick was wonderful it was three
years old at the time we had 108 I was
180th employee software-as-a-service
it's for those of you don't know it it's
the leading technology that delivers and
targets and reports on internet
advertising and Google started around
the same time 1998 so now I was spending
more time in the Internet I was working
at double-click I understood a lot about
the internet night I knew about Google
pretty early on even though I was living
in New York so didn't have the benefit
of being out here in Stanford and you
can see I thought this is one of my
favorites index contains 25 million
pages so this is pretty early in
Google's life back in 1997 in 1998 and
of course I understand that Stanford was
able to get some good royalties from
from Google over the years from the
intellectual property so this is
double-click in the internet bubble we
went public
we went public at a 250 million dollar
market cap that was the day I joined in
1998 three years later the market cap
was 13 billion dollars fortunately I had
I'll tell you that story tube it came
down then and went back down to about
600 million and stayed around that level
until it was bought in a private equity
transaction bought by Helmut Friedman
around 95 and then was sold to Google
last year and double-click is still the
leading internet advertising technology
company so it turns out that the value
that Google paid about four billion
dollars so if you bought in the IPO and
held on through the private equity phase
it sold to Google you made fifteen times
your money over ten years so it's a
great investment but the public market
shareholders didn't always get that
value helmet of Friedman did a
phenomenal job and Helmut Friedman got
more than their fair share of that of
that value but the point here is I had I
had been at first Boston in 1987 when
the stock market dropped 25 percent in
one day and that was a very scary day so
to sit on the trading floor at first
Boston when we all felt the world was
coming to an end
gave us a little bit of experience that
the capital markets were pretty risky
places so when double-click stock went
up substantially we all said business is
great we have plenty of cash from the
IPO we really don't need to raise more
money
I was the I actually that's another
story I up until double-click I was
always the youngest guy in the room
overnight at double-click I was the
oldest guy in the room just it was just
I was what for 1998 I would have been
about 40 years old and everyone else was
about 25 or 28 the CEO is 30 so I'm
saying you know you know even though we
all think the company is going to grow
100 percent every six months which was
the pace that we were on at a 8 9 10
billion dollar market cap for company
with 300 400 million dollars revenue
maybe we should sell some more stock and
we was able to persuade the board to do
that the board actually wanted to do
what the CEO was a little reluctant and
then on the day of the week of this
offering we were raising about 700
million dollars of stock which turned
out to be in March of 2000 which was
exactly the peak of the Nasdaq an
article comes
in Businessweek about over sorry in USA
Today about how DoubleClick's
invading people's privacy and this
privacy was sort of a low-level issue
people really didn't worry much about it
but somehow this USA Today article took
off all the other newspapers TV stations
started new articles about privacy
shareholders started getting spooked our
huge sell orders the roadshow was Monday
started Monday morning was going to
price Thursday night and the article
appeared Wednesday morning Wednesday at
noon I'm on the roadshow I get a call
Nasdaq has stopped trading in our stock
because of an imbalance of sellers so
we're trying to raise all this money the
stocks not trading we get together
Wednesday night say what should we do
some of the executives said you know
what we have plenty of capital we don't
really need the money let's not go ahead
with the offering because we don't want
to somehow reinforce to these privacy
advocates that they can influence our
capital raising and decisions let's just
prove to them we don't need their money
let's just pull up our stakes and go
home and I said no even though the stock
is trading at $110 a share the let
whatever eleven billion dollars at the
time and it's going to go down tomorrow
morning it's still pretty high and we
should probably raise the money so
Thursday morning the stock opens at 90
down from 110 the day before and we go
ahead and fortunately we were able to
actually do the financing so we raised
seven hundred million dollars at $90
share that Thursday night and for the
next couple of months the stock stayed
at that 90 million $90 share level and
within six months it was down to 50 and
a year later it was down to ten so I was
pretty happy with the decision to
continue with the capital raising and
that was a pretty extraordinary week in
my my career okay so the internet bubble
bursts that's now mm - mm mm what
happens the terrorist tax advertising is
way down Internet advertising is
struggling double-click is still losing
money overall even though it's it's
still got we have 700 million of cash in
our checking account so we've got very
strong balance sheet but the revenues
are declining we ended up going from
2,000 employees down to about a thousand
employees from the peak to the trough
during this time
and I say well you know what it's time
for me to get back to a real company a
big company with stability through this
downturn it looked like there's gonna be
a long recession and a friend introduced
me to vnu
which was a conglomerate headquartered
in Holland with an operation in New York
that owned Nielsen Media Research so as
a research data company focused on media
and just to give you a sense of going
from high tech to lower tech Nielsen's
technology was people meters where when
you if you are a Nielsen family you you
push you actually have to go and push a
button to say you're in the room and
then push the button to say you're
leaving the room and that's how they
figure out who's watching television
today in fact in the United States and
you can imagine how that's not 100%
accurate when people do that but there
were millions of people fill out these
paper diaries so most of ratings back
then it's still a lot of ratings today
are based on literally millions of
consumers once a week for a week during
the course of a year filling out a diary
saying what shows that I watch in pencil
or paper mailing it into Florida and
having a lot of retired people come in
and compile the the written diaries and
enter it into the database so that was
the the vnu Nielsen Media Research
high-tech business 2003 I had the
privilege of joining the Priceline Board
of Directors which was has been a
terrific experience that's still on the
board I've been on four public boards
I'm not just on one now so I was the
chairman of the Compensation Committee
and I've been on the Audit Committee
Priceline has made other acquisitions we
are now the largest hotel internet
travel agency in Europe through booking
comm and we've got a terrific business
in Asia called a gota and I hope you're
familiar with Priceline if you're not go
to priceline.com you can get great deals
on hotels so so I'm at vnu it's a large
conglomerate did a lot of acquisition
integration and then advo came along
looking for CFO and I wanted to get out
of being I was a it was a much larger
company with 35,000 people but I was a
divisional CFO I want to get back to the
corporate being a corporate CFO an ad
vote called
they are the largest direct mail company
United States 100% off line wanted to go
on line so they said you're on line
backgrounds terrific we need an
experienced public company CFO advo you
may have you may get this in your mail
but
it's it's it looks it's these coupons
and and and shopper kind of grocery type
of circulars it comes with this card
about missing children which is the
public service that advo does and advo
is accounts for 1% of all the postage in
the United States so it's an enormous
offline print distribution kind of
company we never turns out we never got
online never never were able to do that
and we ended up selling the company for
a 50% premium so and looking back I was
CFO three public companies all of which
got sold also mid-cap companies sort of
billion to 3 billion dollar range King
world was sold now part of CBS advil was
sold to ballasts and double-click was
sold to Google so now announced 2007
still trying to find the next
double-click and a venture capitalist at
Oak Investment Partners introduced me to
O'Brien media which is a leading casual
gain internet casual game company so now
I'm back in a scalable internet
high-tech business growing very quickly
we had terrific customers we had great
investors I thought this perhaps could
be another ten to one or hundred to one
type of return it wasn't and it's grow
bran is doing reasonably well but it's
still a small private company and still
has some some business challenges and
around that time my three children all
our children finally grew up my youngest
daughter was accepted to Stanford and my
wife who'd gone to Stanford and I said
if we're ever going to move back to
Silicon Valley I want to be a high tech
CFO high tech companies are all in
Silicon Valley this is the time to come
back and so I was able to come back last
summer met with a number of different
recruiters companies venture capital
firms private equity firms and just was
lucky enough that when I was looking to
come back to Silicon Valley Oracle was
looking for CFO and I joined Oracle in
September so remember that chart about
the straight line shortest distance
between two points this is my career you
could never predict it it would have led
here but it turns out that remember
Oracle was found in 1977 in 1979 they
moved to 3,000 Sand Hill Circle which is
a mile down the road from where I was at
BCG in 1979
not knowing that Oracle even existed and
I left about a billion dollars in the
table if I had joined Oracle back in
1979 but I I'm delighted to be there
today so so that's a little bit about
the story of my career and I thought I'd
be Jack felt it would be interesting to
share it with you in the interest of
time why don't I just stop there and and
turn over to questions I have other
slides about Oracle we talked about if
you'd like to but thank you very much
it's it's really fascinating talking
that's the first question yes as an
investor I didn't have any money back
then now I have enough money to invest
so I'm asking everyone I mean I asked
the same question what's the next mobile
telephone industry or in an industry and
I I don't really have any great answers
unfortunately but I do think that from a
career point of view it's just your
career will be a lot better if you
happen to be a mystery that's going to
grow 10x over the next 10 or 20 years
because the employment is going to grow
and your responsibilities going to grow
and the value of equity is going to grow
so it's sort of a it's a logical thing
to do if you have a choice of I don't
want to pick on the auto industry but if
you if you go and you work for it RJ was
the CEO afford it but if you go and work
for Ford today compared to going to work
for a company that's going to grow that
has a potential to grow 10x over the
next number of years the the probability
weighted outcome is is going to be a lot
better in that growth area so that you
all probably know a lot more about what
the next Internet's going to be and of
course people are talking about green
tech and anvil and mobile content and
things like that as well but you know
Oracle of course is not going to grow
10x in revenue from where we are today
we're twenty two billion dollars but I
think Oracle still has has the potential
to have very substantial growth and if
you think about when companies like
Microsoft and others when they were
already very large companies they
there's a there's a stage where you
change from a growth company to being
stable and obviously shrinking at some
point and that's a as an analyst if you
all analyzed businesses you look at the
financials you understand the markets
that's a probably a pretty important
question to ask is where is the industry
growing and where is that company within
the industry I feel I'm at Oracle not
just because it's a big company and a
successful company but I also absolutely
believe we have enormous potential to
grow the business of gain market share
yes I hope it is my last job
so I'm Jeff Henley was the CFO before me
at Oracle he was the CFO for 13 years
and he's now the chairman of the board
and spends most of his time with
customers and I spent about 10 percent
of my time with Oracle customers it
turns out customers want to talk to the
Oracle CFO because they're making
multi-million dollar investments in our
software and the CFO is often like the
user of Oracle financials for instance
so I think it's pretty it may be unusual
for other products but certainly in our
business I think the CFO is good for the
CFO to spend some time with customers so
I would love to spend the next 15 years
at Oracle until they kick me out of
being the CFO and if I can if I'm lucky
enough to just have a continuing
involvement with Oracle in any way that
I can be helpful oh that would be that's
my dream I'm now in my dream job after
twelve other jobs that weren't my dream
job necessarily and and I'm I hope I get
to stay here forever yes
it's very different and first of all I
was surprised that Oracle would hire me
because I was in this box of being a
mid-cap company CFO so whenever someone
had a mid-cap media or technology or
advertising company at CFO search I was
on their list then I got a lot of calls
but there was actually another
technology company that I interviewed
for that's much smaller than Oracle that
turned me down because they thought I
was a great candidate but didn't have
big company experience so I feel
fortunate that Oracle gave me the chance
to join this big company now I had been
at vnu which had 35,000 employees and
Oracle has 85,000 so it's not quite as
big but it's it's similar it has 100
countries it's got shared service
centers similar big company
infrastructure and I purposely went to
be in you to check the box so that I
could prove to people that I had big
company experience so I think that was
important in my career to prove that I
at least knew what big companies
operated like the big the biggest
difference for me personally now that
I'm here at Oracle is the amount of
support staff I have so in the other
jobs typically I would have between 100
and 300 people reporting to me at Oracle
I have 4,500 people reporting to me and
what that meant was that most of my
other jobs I was a player-coach
so early in your career I did everything
myself I had no one to delegate to at
places like double-click I was probably
30% doing things myself writing my own
presentations doing my own spreadsheets
and then delegating 70% of the time at
Oracle I'm essentially 100% delegating
and 0% doing anything myself I do I'll
give a presentation but I have someone
who writes the presentations for me I
sit in the accounting meetings but if
there's analysis I ask someone through
the analysis they do the analysis and I
you know I still check the math but I
don't personally do spreadsheets anymore
so that it was a tough transition
because I wanted to do spry I'm good at
spreadsheets so I wanted to to so and it
turned out that there's actually someone
whose job it is to do the spreadsheets
who gets upset if I do them so so and he
probably doesn't much better than I do
now too so so that was the biggest
transition is to understand that I'm
essentially in a role now where my job
is to
hire great people make sure their goals
are aligned motivate them check to make
sure they're doing okay but be a leader
as opposed to being an active personal
contributor and that's over over the
years I've done more and more that but
that but now it's as I said virtually a
hundred percent yes the first question
is the most important thing I learned at
Stanford just one well I learned a lot
you know I had I think it was the
background actually in finance and
accounting so I had a broad range of
classes at Stanford and I remember
distinctly I took two courses in linear
programming which were required and I
was talking to RJ and Jack about this
last night and linear program has anyone
here taken linear programming classes
okay
so linear programming is what you need
if you're running an oil refinery to
know how to optimize the inputs and the
outputs I didn't run an oil refinery so
I actually have never used linear
programming in the last thirty years so
that was actually interesting from a
solving a puzzle point of view but turns
out not to have been helpful to my
career but the finance courses I took
and the county courses I use every day
and and so that's something that was was
critical I would also say the the
interpersonal relations and leadership
courses that I took would have been
important if I really understood what I
was doing back then and that's since I
came right out of college to business
school had never managed people I don't
think I got enough out of it but today
that's as you think about a career those
those are absolutely critical and I wish
I knew more while I was a student to
know what questions to ask and what
parts to learn so this is what was a
second question
the skills that I've learned along the
way well I say you know different people
have different skills that they're
either born with or developed early in
their lives and clearly the analysis
part of something that I've had as a
child all through my whole life has been
sort of that my strengths and I was
fortunate enough to marry a woman who's
got the emotional side which I didn't
have so there's this if people taking
the myers-briggs test here so I've taken
that a couple times and there's there's
a thinking versus feeling spectrum and
I'm about 99 percent thinking and one
percent feeling my wife spent ninety
nine percent feeling one percent
thinking which makes for some
interesting dinner table conversations
but over the years mostly through my
wife the relationship of my wife I've at
least become sensitive to the feelings
side of things in business and business
context in addition to raising my
children and so that's something which
over the years I've tried to balance out
I'm still heavily on the analysis side
but I'd to spend more and more time at
least being sensitive to to the
interpersonal and feeling side question
here how much you guys added to your
skill set just see many different
scenarios
kind of call every two three years I'm
not it's it's I didn't want to do it it
was that there were decisions that some
of them were things where I just I
wanted to take the money go into Wall
Street or the company was doing badly
and couldn't afford to keep me in you
know a double-click was was was falling
so there were decisions that that were
were not optimal and I also went and I
joined companies at some point in my
career early on probably at the King
World Time which is sort of ten years
into my career I would join companies
who had a problem and they brought me in
to solve the problem and I've talked to
other friends of mine who instead went
to really well-run companies and learned
from the best so if you had joined
Goldman Sachs or McKinsey and spent your
career there you learn because you were
surrounded by terrific leaders and
managers and you learn by following them
and most of the companies that I was at
were companies that were struggling and
had problems and I was one of a small
group people who were going in there to
fix the problems which meant that we had
to learn on her own so I didn't get the
chance to learn from others and watch
modeling from other people so if I could
do it again I probably early in my
career would have tried to find a great
company work for a fantastic leader and
just follow him around for a couple of
years and I sort of miss having done
that now at Oracle I I'm just lucky that
Oracle is an incredibly well managed
company Larry Ellison I think is one of
the best businessman in the history of
business as well as Safra Catz and the
other people who are leading Oracle so
I'm learning I'm even now I'm learning a
lot about how to run a terrific company
and it's it's a pleasure to be part of
it it's question back there yes
is that something that you try to change
your own personal risk profile if so how
do you try to do that I'm not sure I was
risk-averse I think I was
I appreciated the option value so I
wanted I wanted to protect the downside
and keep some upside and that's maybe
why I moved around a lot so that I moved
at double click the my equity turned out
to be worth quite a bit of money at
Oberon the equity actually wrote a check
to buy equity and that it might not be
worth Natalie is my stock options not
worth anything about my equity that I
personally paid for might not be worth
so much so I was I was willing to take
some calculated risks in my career and I
think that was just part of my
personality that I felt I I don't think
I would have been comfortable in a pure
startup being one of the first three or
five employees and also what you do
every day if you're one of the first
five employees is quite different than
if you join a company with 180 employees
I felt very comfortable at the
double-click stage where you've got
revenues you've got customers you've got
a number of people who are already doing
their jobs and the question is and at
180 people you basically know every
individual in the company so going from
one hundred eighty to two thousand
people was my at the time my sweet spot
and being at Oracle is a very different
type of thing I'm having to learn how do
you deal with people who you I see I
meet them once then I won't meet them
again for a year or two even if they
work for me so I'm learning that that
new way of dealing yes over here we've
got a bit of a sense of what you love
about an Oracle I was wondering if you
could talk about the aspects of the CFO
role whether it'll be at Oracle
companies that really excite you well
I've I liked finance I like math I like
analysis there's I was at a presentation
the other day from Glenn Hutchins a
partner at Silver Lake partners and he
said in God We Trust all others must
bring data and so that's from from from
when I was young I just I was like that
part of it that you can analyze things
and try to come up with a rational
approach so to me if you thought about
the different functions actually at the
Washington Post company I thought about
this I I loved the idea of being at a
newspaper company and after I was there
I said well how do I have a career in
the newspaper industry and I looked
around and I said well what are the jobs
in a newspaper company there's the CFO
there's the head of manufacturing of
printing and he has to stay up all night
because newspapers are printed at night
so he's running a printing plant well I
don't want to stay up all night run a
printing plan there's the guy in charge
of distribution and he runs a fleet of
trucks to deliver the papers to people
that didn't sound really sexy to me
there's advertising sales which would
have been okay but I'm okay at sales I'm
not a great salesperson their
circulation sales which is more
marketing there's the editor but I'm not
really an editor and then there's Don
Graham's job being the publisher of The
Washington Post newspaper and it
occurred to me that the only job at The
Washington Post newspaper that I really
wanted was Don Graham's job but my name
was it Graham so I couldn't quite figure
out how to get from where I was to being
the publisher of The Washington Post
newspaper which is one reason why I
ended up leaving and actually Allen
spoon became the president of the
Washington Post company but still wasn't
part of the Graham family and he ended
up going to the private equity business
so as I think about those different
functions what are the different jobs
within a corporation finance was the one
that seemed to me to be closest to what
my skill set was and my capabilities and
I and I've loved it so it's it from
early on that felt natural to me yes a
mission you can hop on these days
what if someone creates yet and uh well
each of these companies I could have
stayed there long so if I had stayed at
the Washington Post Company in spite of
RJ's being on the board I would have had
a very different career I probably would
have enjoyed what I did the Washington
Post is an extraordinarily well-run
company and has terrific products but I
probably would not have been able to be
the CFO at Oracle as an example and as a
consultant I liked consulting it was
intellectually interesting but I was I
felt I know whether it's just I had 13
different studies in the three years
that I was there and I don't think there
was a single study that I personally was
involved in where the client did
something material to the client based
on my work they they would they they
read the report they said very
interesting they put in a drawer or they
it was about an acquisition that they
didn't do so maybe I helped them not
lose money but I just felt that it was a
little too theoretical and not practical
enough there so I didn't want to stay a
consulting I could have stayed in
banking and banking was certainly I
think that my friends who stayed in
banking and are now senior executives at
Lazard for instance are very wealthy so
it probably was the right financial
decision but it was mostly most of the
bankers that I knew were great at sales
and I felt that they were better
salespeople than I was and and I just
didn't want to spend my career being a
mediocre salesperson so that was the
decision there yes so you mentioned your
how on what you like to be your last job
so I think your focus now to be in
selecting payments so why would you know
each other servants little jet their
trajectory joins our what can you ask
absolutely your by direct reports yes
and someone who has the same trajectory
in other places what would you write you
know it's very interesting because as as
the CFO I have 14 direct reports who are
all functional experts so there's a head
of tax head of accounting a head of this
financial planning analysis and there's
actually conflict because on the one
hand I want someone who's a generalist
enough to be my successor on the other
hand I want the tax got to be really
good at tax and someone who spends two
years a tax is not going to be as good
as the guy who spent 30 years in tax and
the reason they hired me was because
none of those people were generalists so
they were all they're all very good kind
of the 14 people 13 of them I've kept
one of them I've actually I've kept in
his position but I've hired someone
senior him investor in investor
relations and I ask myself are any of
these 14 people capable in five or ten
years of becoming the CFO and what do I
have to do in terms of their career
development to get them there and the
answer is some of them yes and some of
them maybe not and some of them may not
be able to get the kind of career
experience I've had because they're not
going to be able to be the CFO of
another public company and stay at
Oracle and there's not that many other
places to go with an Oracle so I I have
this the successor planning challenge
and I don't know how it's I'm not
worried about right now because I'm
living there less than a year but at
some point I would have to figure out
how do I develop a successor and give
them that breadth of experience and
it'll probably just be my moving the
same people from one department to
another and trying to give them a chance
at that and maybe send them to do
international assignments maybe taking
them out of finance and having them go
into operations for a few years that
come back to finance so I don't have an
easy answer but it's a critical question
as they think about their careers and as
I think about succession planning yes
well I report to Safra Catz who's the
president who reports to Larry so
there's a another level behind and Safra
has that relationship so Safra has known
Larry for 20 years
she was initially his banker at DLJ and
has now been the president of the
company for 10 years and she is in
effect the chief out her role is
essentially the chief operating officer
where Larry makes many of the key
strategic decisions Safra makes them
happen and I help Safra implement them
so I don't think there's a near-term
likelihood that Larry is going to look
to me for advice and many things so it's
and I'm fine with that I have a seat at
the table I'm in the meetings I get a
chance to voice my opinion but there are
other people who have seats at the table
who have a lot more experience at Oracle
and NIT and Larry's got a pretty good
track record of making decisions
regardless of other people's advice so
so I look forward over years actually
you know Jeff Henley was someone who
came into Oracle at a time when Oracle
was struggling they were they had some
very substantial cost problems and and
Larry did look to Jeff for someone who
had a different experience set had
clearly had of CFOs view of the world
which is different from Larry's which
was an engineer's view of the world and
Jeff definitely developed that
relationship with with Larry it still
has it
Safra has that now and so certainly my
goal over a number of years would be to
develop that but I think I have to earn
that credibility over time yes a new
perspective where is big challenge
well we have an ear charge challenge
which is we've agreed to acquire Sun
Microsystems and we've been a software
company son as a software and assistance
company so we're now expanding it to a
new area we have a philosophy of
offering our customers complete open and
integrated products and we and the idea
strategy behind buying son is that if we
can design the systems and the software
to work together the way that Apple's
iPod for instance iPod and iTunes were
designed by the engineers to work very
closely together works great as a
combined software and hardware system
we'd like to do that with son hardware
and Oracle software so that's probably
the single greatest near-term challenge
for Oracle and then longer-term it's how
do we continue to innovate come up with
great products and and grow our market
share in the world of I T and I T is
this the enormous marketplace we have
very strong position we have essentially
everywhere an enterprise software
company so we don't do consumer we don't
do small business or our customers are
large enterprises governments
not-for-profits so I think we're at the
we're at the part of the market where
they have the customers have a lot of
money and have a lot of great needs and
I think we have a terrific opportunity
to continue to build products that help
solve our customers problems and will
generate revenue and profit growth for
us great well I think that's so we're
out of time it's 1:00 o'clock so I want
to be sensitive to your schedule thank
you very much I've had a wonderful time